[Musik]
es ist der moment der ein ganzes land
aufatmen lässt videobilder der
thailändischen navy seals zeigen den
augenblick als die retter die seit tagen
vermisste jugendfußballmannschaft und
ihren trainer findet und nach kurzer
nachfrage ist klar alle sind der
verhältnisse entsprechend wohlauf und am
leben
seit tagen suchten spezialisten und
sondereinheiten nach den jugendlichen in
dem labyrinth artige höhlensystem
wahrscheinlich war die gruppe überrascht
worden als die höhle wegen schwerer
regenfälle überflutet wurde
die helfer hatten darauf gehofft dass
sich die fußballmannschaft auf fels
erhöhung in einer der höhlen habe retten
können
jetzt sollen die jugendlichen unter
fußballtrainer versorgt werden damit sie
wieder zu kräften kommen können die
thailändischen einsatzkräfte arbeiten
nach eigenen angaben daran eine
strategie zu entwickeln wie sie die
gruppe wohlbehalten aus der noch immer
überfluteten höhle bringen können